hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we're going over one of my
favorite fights from throughout the dopa
series that is tatsuki fujimoto's
chainsaw man so that this may not be the
flashiest or craziest fight in the
series but personally I think that this
fight here the chainsaw man vs Katana
man battle which puts our reps at the
bureau against some dirty ass gun devil
agents as one of the greatest fights in
the entire series especially the first
half of it as it symbolizes the moment
pretty much everything changes inside of
the world like our perception gets
utterly flipped on its head as we
realize the true brutality that this
Series has in store and not just that
it's the moment that I think you start
to realize just how good tatsuki
fujimoto's writing actually is as
everything that he's been building up
with dingy and this story so far over
the previous 40 chapters starts falling
perfectly into place also I did get hit
with the big three as you can probably
hear yourself first it was the pup who I
had to rush to the vets as she was
having seizures but luckily she's turned
out perfectly fine after only two nights
at the Vets then I had my freaking
wisdom teeth start coming through
literally messing up my jaw and then on
top of that I had to get horrendously
sick at the same time which just ruined
my entire upload schedule as I was stuck
in bed for almost two odd weeks however
I'm slightly starting to feel better now
so subscribers we're only like 1K of
100K so that's actually freaking mean
too and I can't thank you all enough for
the support as it's just been freaking
crazy but anyway enough of me creaming
over how well the Channel's been doing
recently time for me to jump into this
Ramen store just before everything kicks
off so as I just said we start off
inside of a Ramen Shop and while the
main Court of division 4 chills out they
hear a bunch of gunshots in the distance
but they just assume that they're merely
drum beats is this so far away a
stranger on the table next to them
speaks up insulting the quality of the
ramen the engine power who hear this are
both offended by her and the man sitting
their comments on the piers unrefined
palette remarking that those who do not
eat much in their youth gain a poor
sense of taste later in life since then
there's something's wrong Aki tells them
all to leave but the random man
continues talking he begins discussing
his beloved grandfather whom would often
spoil him then in a moment that probably
makes dingy start tripping he reveals
his grandfather to be the old man who
raised dingy and was later possessed by
the zombie devil he accuses dinghy of
causing the old man's death what she's
not gonna lie bro my man kind of messed
up your granddad pretty sure he's lying
somewhere inside of like some [__] cut
into a bunch of different pieces looking
like a burrito or something anyways this
random man then states that the gun
devil wants his heart hit him whips out
a gun and shoots dingy in the head
killing him before shooting her menu in
the chest and are he in the arm before
he can continue though habisco power
punches him knocking the gun out of his
hand Aki then instantly summons the fox
devil to Devour the mysterious dude
looking over he worriedly sees dingy's
dead and unmoving body as well as
amino's critically injured State taking
Aki by surprise though the fox devil
then suddenly informs him that the man
was neither human nor devil before its
head is viciously torn apart from the
inside and the man re-emerges revealing
himself to be a devil human hybrid fused
with the one and only Katana devil Aki
orders power to stop him in his bleeding
thing then pulls out his Infamous sword
and unsheets it for the first time
looking at it power is the price to see
that it resembles a nail rather than a
blade initiating the battle the katana
man swings at him but Aki Dodges before
really in his blade and shouting fire
eerily a devil slightly appears and is
shown flicking the Nail's Point into the
katana man's body as a disembodied mouth
is then seen sounding the number three
confused with what just happened the
katana man hesitates before swinging
Nikki in Aki once again Dodges shouting
fire once more and pissing the devil
human hybrid once again again the
disembodied voice speaks saying the
number two finally akimaxi lunge pissing
the katana man's belly and he curses
voice States one the katana man knocks
him back showing confusion over his plan
however Aki calls it out to the devil
telling it to finish him as the devil
appears at state zero causing a massive
disembodied hand to grow and grab the
katana man momentarily he expresses
shock before literally being taught Lim
from Lim by a giant skeletal devil then
being left to fall to the law
unconscious and bleeding profusely
archic calls out to power who recommends
getting him into a doctor leaving him
shocked as he remembers the use of a gun
and the man's ominous statement
regarding the gun devil suddenly a young
woman appears commenting on the
kerstevil's power seeing her Aki asks
whether or not she's working with a
katana man stepping forward the girl
doesn't even respond and simply picks
back up the hybrid she asks the katana
man why he lost so easily to which he
ashamedly responds that he let down his
guard re-initiating the battle she
orders him to kill the group quickly
leading the katana man to Lunge forward
at arkey and before a boy can even
respond his chest is suddenly slashed by
the katanas protruding from him Aki
who's heavily injured from the attack
then drops to the floor salatari who's
the chick by the way I completely forgot
to introduce her name but yeah anyway
she comments on how the wounds are
likely non-fatal due to the bureau's
suits being reinforced with a special
material himuno tells power to forget
about her and instead help Aki however
power just refuses as she's really
terrified and believes herself to be far
outmatched hamunu attempts to summon the
ghost devil but it refuses out of pure
fear of sawatari and her curse as a last
resort in an attempt to save Aki hamino
offers her everything to the ghost devil
instantly the devil's Grimace turns to a
smile as its true giant form is finally
revealed the ghost evil then starts to
attack the katana man and with each
attack himino loses more and more of her
body sacrificing it all to her devil as
this happens she thinks back about her
love which is you know Archy if you're
all confused and remarks on how unusual
it is that he was still able to cry as
most devil Hunters grow emotionally
stunted over time as Aki looks at her
she tells him not to die and she still
wants someone to be able to cry over a
death damn so you know I ain't come
through with the Holy cutoffs this video
so far but this is the exact moment in
the series where I truly realize just
how messed up tatsugi Fujimoto is dude
is like gigay and they regard that he
just does not care about your damn
emotions at all he's a Damon who's legit
just trying to actually destroy them
like the series takes such a drastic
turn at this exact specific point
anyways anyways es salutari someone's a
snake devil ordering it to devour
hamino's devil it does so launching a
bunch of attacks and leaving nothing at
all of amino aside from their clothes
laying on the floor
sawatari and the katana man then turn to
dingy's incapacitated body says him that
their goal is to take his heart but as
they say this the ghost Devils die hand
is somehow seen floating towards denji's
body somehow himinu literally comes
through clutch even after dying and
tears the freaking cord on his chest
Reawakening and finally transforming him
into the chainsaw man though he's
initially confused by the current
situation dingy instantly recognizes
that the katana man and so Atari are his
enemies like the absolute psychover is
he excitedly charges at him stating that
he loves bad guys as no one cares how he
brutally kills them so Atari noting that
she is missing some of her fingernails
calls for backup over a walkie-talkie
then looks over at Aki who's still in
complete shock over himino's death two
backup agents then arrive and begin
firing guns at dingy though he gets shot
he is able to knock both of the fodder
falls down then takes one as a hostage
pissed off the katana man who just
couldn't care at all about this random
agent slices through him and dingy
cutting him both in half at a speed
dingy was unable to even register
picking up Genji's mutilated top half
the katana man orders the other agents
to get the car around remarking that the
other members of the fourth division are
likely already dead due to their
vulnerability to guns which for like
those of you who are confused about like
the other members of defore well like
just before the Ramen Shop stuff pretty
much they all got shot on the head by a
bunch of dudes walking around town who
ambushed them anyways skipping forward
from the fight over to Mummy makima just
after his stunts on all of the fools who
like somehow thought they took her out
after she comes out of the train covered
in blood and messing up some of the
agents makima theorizes that the gun
agents are currently going after dingy
to combat this she orders tendo and
corros to find her a shrine with a high
elevation and 30 criminals with life
sentences as well as a change of clothes
bag with dingy and his messed up body a
few gun agents move his top half into
the car but as they do so one begins to
weirdly swear remarking how strange he
feels all of a sudden in an instant his
body's flattened by an invisible force
horrifying all of his compatriots Panic
salutary calls to team e asking them to
reconfirm makima's death for team C
however as they all Panic an A-Team
agent responds commenting that they've
lost contact with sea team but as he
says this he is too flattened
mid-sentence Becca the shrine is Mummy
makima enacts her freaking death ritual
Tyndall and kuros stand nearby as well
as 30 blindfolded prisoners who have all
been lowered to their knees being ready
for their impending death Tinder informs
corros that Judo high ranking the nature
of the devil mahima has a contract with
is kept completely classified makima
then orders a prisoner to say the name
mashima shuzo to which he complies over
at the van the gun agent named mushima
shuzo is instantly flattened by another
invisible force protag Markham has got
the death note or something right now
anyway back of the shrine The Prisoner
then Falls dead as markima who couldn't
care less about the previous dude then
instructs the next prisoner to say
another name and so on and so on
throughout the entire country multiple
gun agents are constantly flattened over
and over and over as a result of
machima's curse suddenly she stops then
instructs corrodes Nintendo to take off
their blindfolds telling them that she
is done all she can do from their
current location back at the van and
just panicked with the situation of
people dying around her so Atari orders
the katana man's hurry up and move
dingy's body before makima can interfere
any further as he does this though he
suddenly sees a random figure moving
towards them which turns out to be the
family supporting girl no one other than
kabini who's clutching a good old
freaking kitchen knife kabini asks
sawatari and the katana man whether or
not they are affiliated with the gun
devil not concerned with the arrival of
kabini Salvatore summons the snake
Devil's Tail to attack her but somehow
cabani's agility literally skyrocketed
and she easily Dodges it before running
along its body towards the two the
katana man tries to shoot at her but
kabini is just way too damn Quirk and
she easily slices his arm off first then
like on some Matrix level shirt she
grabs the gun and shoots him in the back
then turns her aim towards so Atari the
curse wielder though Fires at her first
but being cabani she is the world's
biggest brain and actually uses denji's
reinforced chainsaw head to deflect the
bullets so without we realizing that she
could die here grabs the katana man and
drags him into the car then drives away
kabini who's now looking down at denji's
unconscious torso apologizes for trying
to kill him in the past slowly is the
realization of everything sets in
growing slowly hysterical as she
remembers a rise dead body before
deciding she plans to tell that she
quits the team which is you know like
hella said as she doesn't even realize
that at this moment Amino is currently
dead but you know that there does bring
the end of the first battle to a close
and one that I find completely changes
just the overall outlook on the series
through the short but like insanely
brutal first battle here one in which
Genji really isn't the main fighting
force for the first time he wait behind
what everyone does increases tenfold
because simply we know for a fact that
those characters were considered
unkillable as they were a part of like
what we think are like the key cast are
actually killable it's like the moment
an if you may be where Hughes gets
ambushed and actually dies inside of the
phone booth it changes the dynamic of
everything and just makes us realize
that the enemy won't stop at nothing to
get the goal completed anyways anyways
skipping forward to the beginning of the
Second Battle now and of course if you
want to know exactly what happened in
between these two battles because I'm a
lot the implications of amino's death
Aki using his curse tool too much him
getting a new Devil the stuff that goes
down is actually freaking mental in
between these two fights so if you are
interested and want to know more then be
sure to check out my video going over
the entire Katana Man Arc from chainsaw
man as that explains absolutely
everything but anyway anyway so as the
Second Battle was about to take place
the bureau all prepared to storm the gun
engines building the bureau by the way
is just like the Japanese Hunters
Association pretty much inside of the
building solitary talks to the katana
man reaffirming the plan to kill his
many devil Hunters as possible and steal
dingy's heart outside kashibi orders the
hunters the stormy building while at the
same time a pack of zombies lie in
weight below them still outside kashiba
introduces himself to the second
division leader for Runo and the popo
Shina who are in charge of locking down
the building he gives a rundown of the
various non-human members of his special
fourth division inside of the building
now fighting inside of the building we
see this crazy looking shark thing
called beam who appears and begins
devouring these zombies and as frenzy he
accidentally bites another member of the
fourth division the violence Fame who in
turn knocked him down before apologizing
continuing to attack more zombies the
violence vein notices a woman nearby and
warns her to stay away before realizing
that she's also a devil and is in fact
the spider devil called princey she then
stands up and decapitates a zombie's
head Who falls down and rolls over to
the feet of the angel devil who begins
aiding away the various bodies our boy
Aki then shows up on the Block and
begins cutting through the horde of
zombies seeing him the ancient evil asks
Aki for a handkerchief to clean some
blood off him before explaining to Aki
that he absorbs others life spans
through touch and a surprise at how
close arki has gotten to him suddenly a
gunman appears and tries shooting the
two of them but Angel simply deflects
the bullets while Aki closes and only do
and stabs him then continuing on his own
he eventually comes face to face with
the snake [__] so Atari instantly she
does the most messed up thing you could
ever possibly imagine and uses her devil
to release aminos ghost evil which is
now completely subservient to her seeing
this Aki moves forward deflecting most
of the devil's attacks as his new
Devil's ability the future devil now
which you know like you can go watch my
video and get a good info on gives him
the ability ability to slightly see the
future however he is still quickly
overwhelmed by all of the arms the ghost
devil has and is soon being strangled by
the creature itself going into a
flashback Aki remembers an early meeting
with Amino one in which she offered him
a cigarette however once you realize
that he's underage she takes it back and
Promises to him to give it back when he
really needs to rely on something back
in the present Aki looks up having been
released from the ghost Devil's grasp
from amongst its mass amino's right arm
reaches out holding a cigarette taking
it Aki sees the words easy Revenge
written across it taking a deep breath
he steps forward and while remembering
amino's words he reflects that the ghost
devil is blind so it senses its
surroundings based on fear alone keeping
himself calm like he climbs atop the
ghost devil before promising himino that
he'll die soon and join her he then
swings his sword down decapitating the
ghost devil and frame himino from the
snake's observience shocked with the
tune of events sabitarian moves to
summon the snake devil but is stopped by
our girl kabini who's holding a good old
kitchen knife to the girl's throat Aki
orders cabani not to kill her them
realizing that she didn't actually quote
he asks her why she's still even here to
what she awkwardly responds that she was
close to earning her bonus pay and for
all of those who know exactly what she
bought with her bonus pay when she did
get it you know let me know down in the
comment section below because I know
exactly what it is and it's such a
beautiful piece of Machinery if you ask
me over at the gun agent headquarters
and using an elevator with dinchy power
begins chomping down on a severed zombie
hand which disgusts stingy causing the
two to break out into a miniature
scuffle as the two absolute freaking
morons argue together the elevator doors
finally open revealing a large swarm of
zombies right in front of them due to
the zombies somehow not even noticing
them because they're dumber than the
freaking duo in the elevator didn't you
recommend they stay quiet and utilize
the element of surprise however power
being her usual loud self begins
screaming out and challenging these
zombies to a death battle she bravely
steps forward and begins fighting as a
overwilded and annoyed dingy remains in
the elevator believing that a bro dingy
is still watching her power easily
slashes away through dozens of hulking
zombies boasting that she is the
strongest person alive as dingy who you
know just stayed in the elevator now
arrives on the highest floor he prepares
to tear his freaking let it rip switch
but when the elevator door opens and he
sees The Guitar Man along with a few of
his agents the katana man instantly asks
him to just chill out for a sec so he
can ask dingy a few questions he
explains his group's desire for
compensation over the old man's death
but dingy who's obviously just
frustrated with hearing the snail tries
explaining a game that it wasn't his
fault the old man was zombified when he
had killed him however the katana hybrid
just doesn't believe this no instead the
katana man asks dingy whether he truly
felt nothing when killing zombies
reminding him that they used to be
humans at some point dingy repeats
though that he felt absolutely nothing
big samurai man then reveals that
despite giving his his heart to a devil
unlike dingy he still feels guilt over
killing zombies he goes on to say that
dingy is the only devil human hybrid
without a sense of conscience and
morality he questions dingy to just
accept death as a form of mercy killing
but our boy who just couldn't even care
less casually responds that he don't
wanna causing an irritated Katana man to
take off his hand and transform into his
killing form with the two now
transformed they clash and crash through
a nearby wall which drops the duo
sitting and Falling Towards the streets
below the katana man and dingy glide
through the air while still in combat
and falling as dingy gets pushed back he
falls and lands atop a moving train
reading himself in time he is able to
block an attack from this still falling
Katana man which seems both of them
crashing into a crowded Carriage as
floods of terrified passengers began
flaying a voice over announces that the
train is coming to an emergency stop
dingy notices a single remaining
passenger who turns out to be an injured
woman lying on the floor as Samurai boy
launches another attack at dingy man let
the pure melon grevin gentleman he is
blocks the freaking attack while
protecting the woman but loses his
entire arm in the process the woman
thankfully runs away as dingy then
angrily shouts that they should ban
their move which is you know the exact
same move there they missed Angie up of
last time when he cut him in half the
katana attacks again easily slicing off
dinghy's other arm he then demands that
as long as dingy can no longer fight he
should apologize for killing the old man
and accept death which is just like bro
you still going on about that old fool
he died in the first freaking episode
man even people watching this video have
already seen your grandpa get turned
into a freaking zombie burrito bro just
chill out anyway didn't you refuses
Stacy that as long as he has his
chainsaw on his head he can still fight
the two then Clash again however the
impact causes the blade on dinji's
chainsaw kid to shatter the katana man
again demands an apology in return for a
swift death but this time danger reveals
that the katana Andy was so distracted
with anger that he didn't even notice
literally being sliced in half by
dingy's chainsaw in the egg the katana
man now revealed to have been split
vertically in half would just like to
hambrow those poor nuts and really cut
in half anyways he reacts with a moment
of surprise before his body completely
falls apart into a mass of blood and
organs standing above him dingy repeats
the words told to him by his master big
freaking kashibe earlier on in their
training prey should never trust what a
Hunter says
so this officially brings us to the very
end of what is the chainsaw man vs
Katana man battle or the two battles
that they have where the bureau is put
it up against the people who are kind of
working with the gun agents here or the
supposed you know like gun agents that
we find out later on may not even be
true obviously if you guys want to know
more about you know like chainsaw man in
general then make sure you check out my
entire chainsaw man story explained or
just like the katana Man story arc
explained where it goes over a lot more
of the stuff that I've I've kept out of
this video here and just more focused on
what is my like pretty much I'd say it's
my favorite fight it's definitely up
there in terms of say like my favorite
fights and Chainsaw man so far just to
turn from what was going on in the story
beforehand with dingy kind of taking out
every single villain or devil that we've
gone up against so far and now finally
having like this different kind of
aspect where you've got two enemies and
you've kind of got one person for Aki to
go up against then you've got one person
for dingy to go up against and then the
whole like perspective of the world
changing in like regards to what can
actually happen like characters that you
don't think can die can actually die in
this series and it's it's like Game of
Thrones or like Jujutsu Kaizen or just
like another it's just really comparable
to like great series out there so I
absolutely love chainsaw man in general
and if you guys want me to cover any
more of the fights and go back over them
and you know re-edit them like I have
here from chainsaw man then let me know
down in the description below and I'll
be sure to do that you know over the
next like month or two while chainsaw
man is releasing also I just you know
like at the start of the video I said
you know pushing for 100 000 Subs I just
want to thank everyone for a hundred
thousand Subs now honestly didn't expect
you know by the time I started editing
this video three days ago till now I
would have hit 100 000 Subs but I
somehow did so it's blowing my mind and
you know thank you to everyone who has
subscribed to the channel and just
enjoyed the content that I have been
putting out for the last like year and a
half now it's been absolutely awesome
and you've made a dream of mine like
literally come true this is something
I've wanted to do since the age of 16
years old where I used to sit back and
jam out and make Minecraft videos like
if you've seen my freaking Minecraft
Texture Pack video that I've still got
on the channel I just don't want to
delete it you know like for Nostalgia
reason and all that kind of stuff but
anyway obviously hit that subscribe
button if you haven't already don't know
what you're doing here if you haven't
had that subscribe button yet like
you're actually you're smoking on
something you shouldn't be but anyway
for now it's been your professional did
you know develo and I will see you all
in April bye